e
[Musique]
la vie c'est tout con est astucieux
belle
la fugue au lit le plus sérieux et a
joué aujourd'hui
il s'est dit de vouloir revenir à un ami
bonjour bonjour moi aujourd'hui comme ça
bonjour à tous pour moi bien ça va fort
bien et toi et même moi je vais bien
dieu tu pourrais me rend dingue qui
servit jeu si tu veux je voudrais que tu
donnes son biberon petit tout petit ou
alors à toi tu sais j'ai pas l'habitude
de donner le biberon m'enfin je vais
essayer à les attentions typique huillet
là c'est bon pour lui pour dessein il a
l'air d'aimer ça oui bah c'est fini car
si l'homme à césar après ça il va voir
leur a dit merci bien fabrice au revoir
titou oh la la il est content a dit dans
didon fabrice vial
tu as une expérience les présidents
jerry page et préparer quelque chose
d'intéressant que vous pouvez tous
réalisés avec simplement un petit peu
d'attention en effet je te propose tout
quand cory de faire passer cette carte
postale qui est une simple carte postale
autour de ta tête
ah c'est pas possible c'est pas possible
et cooke et bah si c'est possible c'est
tout petit une carte postale va oui bah
nous allons la faire passer autour de
tâter aulas comment nous allons procéder
d'abord vous prenez une carte postale et
vous la plier en deux et vous dans le
sens de la longueur
on l'appliqué comme ça j'ai un petit peu
préparés l'expérience pour que ça aille
plus vite
ensuite vous avez une paire de ciseaux
et pour que vous voyez mieux à la caméra
imaginez que cette carte postale plié en
deux comme cela soit ce grand morceau de
papier pliée en deux c'est exactement la
même chose
seulement vous verrez beaucoup mieux
alors tu sais que ce n'est pas bête non
c'est pas un
d'un côté vous avez la paire de ciseaux
et vous commencez à couper comme ceci je
vais essayer que ça puisse se voir
voilà on coupe on ne va pas jusqu'au
bout
on s'arrête puis on prend dans l'autre
sens et on recoupe je vous montre le
principe bien et puis on retourne encore
une fois et on recoupe tout le lot tout
le long voilà je ne vais pas le faire
jusqu'au bout parce que ça prendrait
beaucoup de temps
ensuite lorsque vous avez fait cela vous
couper au milieu
ici sans vous occuper de la première
petite languette la première vous l'a
laissée intacte mais vous coupez les
autres au milieu
rioux voilà comme ça vient alors à
partir de ce moment là nous allons
reprendre
nous allons reprendre ce que j'avais
préparé tout à l'heure je vois toujours
pas comment mater de peut passer là
dedans voilà le résultat de la carte
postale
une fois entièrement découpé le voyez ça
c'est une carte postale découpé et pour
passer la carte postale autour de la
tête ce n'est pas très compliqué
regardez le collier extraordinaire que
vous pouvez former c'est très grand
c'est même extrêmement grand voyez vous
ça se déplie et je te messieurs meuwly
décor autour de la tête tu as donc la
carte postale autour de la terre on joue
à la théorie de la carte postale
formidable à et tu vois si ces grands
regarde moi ça énorme mais on peu plus
leurs voiliers après à non là vaut mieux
pas parce que je lirai pas grand-chose à
bâcher très bien voilà je l'enlève je te
la mets de côté tu pourras t'amuser à
recommencer l'expérience lorsque tu
voudras eva derrière ça fait une bonne
mise en route pour jouer aux mots
d'amour m la formidable à un aller j'y
vais oui moi aussi d'ailleurs je viens
alors le mot à mot je vous rappelle
qu'il s'agit tout simplement de regarder
un certain nombre de cartes sur
lesquelles nous avons dessiné des objets
des personnages des animaux et caetera
et à partir de ces objets de ces
personnages qui sont en général exprimé
par une seule syllabe
on forme d'autres mots que j'ai pu voir
que tout cancan belles belles pousses
moussio piquant bull sont très forts à
ce jeune on n'y voit combien c'est dur à
dire c'est mentir ça dacquois oui c'est
un peu difficile m'enfin on arrive à se
débrouiller quand même on se concentre
et moi j'en ai pris là
c'est bon alors tout quand on y regarde
bien c'est une roue nous sommes d'accord
une roue bon ça c'est une vie bien joué
ça c'est une selle une selle
parfaitement pouces monsieur là nous
avons un rôti oui mais nous ne l'emploie
rompt pas dans ce sens là nous
utiliserons le vieux mot d'euros 1 re et
rod est un voleur et oui dans les fables
de la fontaine on utilise vie l'euro et
ça c'est un verre qui commence alors
comment ce mois ne m'a rien match ne va
rien leur gardien putois je sais je sais
plus à celles qu'on peut faire vers tu
prends vert je prends vers huy et la
roue verrouille verrou oui formidable
encore minutes c'est bien vers ou
vérifier l'orthographe que tu écris v e
ri r oui r oui après chez puma aux u11
u10
voilà comment ça s'écrit un verrou c'est
bien joint tous les cas oiseaux tout
confort avec les trois autres mais je
n'arrive pas ici que celle d'havas on en
tire au lac kir une autre gare dirait
notre ami ou aux failles et aguettant
content content de les trouver des
paillons qua non non tout est propre et
en suivant toujours fait ça
ça y est j'ai trouvé quelque chose oui
qu'est-ce qu'il ya plein de ma le mât
parlement où est ce que tu vois ma toi
ah bon bah enfin pour ce monsieur était
complètement malade il n'ya pas de mal
alors on pourrait chercher un tu peux
pas me tirer un mât bat angers alors
s'ils font plus que je me prépare les
choses alors l'algérie chat c'est pas
normal ça laisse aussi je vais prendre
encore quelques quand je tombe sur le
lad tu sais le garçon qui s'occupe des
chevaux y est t'as de la chance parce
qu'on allemand à baa1 c'est là qu'est ce
que tu vas me faire avec ça moi j'avais
bien trouver autre chose mais enfin moi
je n'ai trouvé un vase i mas le ma wii
la wii jeu terry et lads malades à la
plata
en face à presque triche et là oh oui
j'avais continue qu'on continue parce
qu'on était à égalité faut savoir
qu'elle révèle fort malade
l es tu tires tu tires autre chose
qu'est ce que moi je trouvais que
c'était bien comme ça qu'est ce que
c'est que ça c'est toi ça regarde bien
difficile quand c'est toi oui oui c'est
moi mais alors ça je vais t'expliquer
fabrice oui c'est l'autre joker à que
c'est à dire ça peut remplacer tous les
mots que tu veux abanda côté si l'ap que
payés oui ni non ça c'est pratique
quoi tu tout quand on bat parce que je
ne sais pas celui qui avait commencé le
jeu le premier mais alors qu'est ce que
tu me proposes avec ce jeu alors attends
ya rouille avis al aroui avis ni vers
vers la voie inverse non je remplace la
mer
j'utilise de joker pour vous est ouvert
mais bon si tu veux place à côté denis
oui ça fait vernis wernick voilà je t'ai
écrit comment tout qu'encore un substrat
comme en écriture vernis ces derni er
agnès bâillon alors venise1 vernis voilà
oui c'est bien joué bien jouer en indoor
à vos wii qui va avoir le droit de
choisir la carte postale bien embêté la
voilà alors je vais tirer au sort tient
alors allez allez allez vous chemoul su
aller à bath a les poches mais quelques
attardés tu comprennes le regarde a
toujours gardé la n'a pas de problème
elle vient de nicolas et xavier roulant
habitants boulevard gouvion saint cyr
c'est à paris
et nous parle de l'émission de bell bell
je vois qu'à une bise à push moussu tu
vois bien fait plaisir à la séquence
quand je suis là très fort
le petit lait petit nicolas et xavier
roulants vont recevoir le disque de la
chanson des quatre amis bien contents
pour moi c'est bien voilà je me la met
de côté la salle fabrice giletta nous
oui
alors notre petit jeu carton marqueur
alors cette semaine à un mot en huile
être un avis la truite
la première la première c1 c'est un c1
c'est alors je fais citerai oui dans la
dernière un t1 t1 p comme théodore comme
todt rien inutile de dire que c'est un
moyen de transport
oui comme ce que nous jouons avec les
moyens de transport on exactement est ce
que ce n'est rien de transport que qui
va sur l'eau oh non non non non prend
les airs non plus sur des rails non plus
non on s'en sert principalement à la
campagne voiture à la compagnie
alors est ce que est ce que l'on cultive
les champs avec rabat n'ont pas
spécialement non sincère mais on ne
trouve pas spécialement les champs avec
ça ça a des rouges support à salé rouge
à lewis a dénoncé tiré par par des
chevaux aussi des fois c'est tiré un
moteur non n'y a pas de plan que tu que
je te donne la troisième oui alors la
troisième lettre c'est un à un ah oui
voilà à bon là avec tout ça tu devrais
ohlala est-ce que s comment tu m'as dit
de lettres et ben huile être vite
annoncé pas possible ça pousse mots si
tu t'en vouloir tromper tu veux tu
penses à chariot je parais et chariots
olalalala un chariot alors comment tu
l'écris et bah c'est un chat de zaire et
au thé nature à riom naturellement ch à
m
inventif haute et on n'a pas besoin de
mettre 2 ra chariot ah oui ouistes un
sol air à bages avec la légère parce que
4,4 où je pensais un trou légère oui je
vois pas là bas ça fait rien un importe
quoi bon avec huta puisque c'est comme
ça on va directement à les retrouver
belle beille bonne idée si la musique
toi mon cher fabry women belge et habite
à jouer à notre petit jeu musical ok
alors je te raconte l'histoire d'une
chanson reviendront je laisse
certainement inachevé étude devra
compléter ces mots par des notes de
musique que tu placera sur cette portée
musicale
je suis preuve voilà alors tu sais
qu'après ce sera le début d'une chanson
que je vais évoquer c'est une histoire
très seule et je suis sûr que tu vas
reconnaître encore plus vite que
d'habitude la chance tu ne protestait
même pathologie toi j'ai confiance
d'ailleurs il est pratiquement un peuple
bleu que tu ne trouves pas impossible
c'est parfait ça va bien je crois bien
que c'est une des toutes premières
chansons qu'on chante aux enfants
peut-être même la première des six est
une chanson qu'on accompagne de gestes
ce qui fait que ça devient presque du
nema a dû cinéma on met ses deux mains
en avant dans la chance aucun les fait
tourner en respectant bien le rythme de
la musique parce qu'il faut absolument
respecter la mesure absolument parfait
je suis sûr que toi aussi tu as eu droit
ce petit cinéma quand il était un petit
garçon bien sage tu t'imagines dans ta
petite barboteuse gentiment aa
sur une chaise à six salles il est
d'ailleurs probablement un peu endormi
et pas très très éveillé réveillés au le
rire oui c'est parfois bon alors eu pour
arriver à faire naître un sourire sur
ton visage quand ils étaient petits
j'étais obligé de chanter ça il n'y
avait évidemment qu'une puce ion et
solutions c'était un somme une manière
de te donner ta première leçon de sel
avant de solfège parfait alors lille et
batouala la science en file 18 600 s'y
résolve asie on attend oui ça me
rappelle quelque chose ça n'avait pas de
moi attention à ses enfants
les petites mares et impuissant rajuste
qui la connaissaient titou chaque la
grotte mois fallait alors une pochette
est là j'arrive en chattant typique on
est venu par yves clarisse et axa sont
déjà papa d'amy
[Musique]
ils se plaignent que la vie m'a fait
désiste et rzeszow fait des choses mais
comme je n'ai pas de minois mais robert
attention les canaris sont traqués sans
répit et iax a mis son de retard izay
blâmer
oui
compris
m
mais david a joué aujourd'hui
et de vouloir devenir amis
[Musique]
élite